joe biden hints his health might stop
him from running again for president the
facts are out on oh macron and they cut
against panic and a democratic
congresswoman who back to defund the
police gets carjacked i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with vpni
trust visit
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
in just one moment first if you're
anything like me one more headline about
the stock market you might just go crazy
because inflation just hit a 29-year
high in december that's the highest in
almost three decades certain investors
are rethinking their portfolio mix what
if i told you you could diversify your
portfolio with an alternative asset
class many elite people have been
quietly putting their money into for
centuries of course i'm talking here
about blue chip works of art price
appreciation has outpaced the s p 500
index from 1995 all the way to 2020 and
now there's finally a way to unlock
access to that asset class many
millionaires invest in that without
being one with the one billion dollar
fintech startup masterworks masterworks
dot io it's giving everyone access to
the once exclusive art market allowing
investors to build a portfolio with
paintings from iconic artists like
picasso and banksy all at a more
affordable price point you can't afford
a picasso i hate to break it to you but
what you can't afford is like a fraction
of a picasso which means that you could
have an asset class that appreciates
heavily in value pretty much every year
they're also giving my listeners
priority access to their newest
offerings get started on your investment
journey at masterworks dot io slash ben
again that's masterworks dot io slash
ben before deciding to invest carefully
review the important disclosures at
masterworks dot io
disclaimer alrighty so
joe biden was interviewed last night
about his future
and he sort of let it slip that he is
thinking about not running again so he
makes it sound as though it's inevitable
that he's going to run again but
his attitude is completely the opposite
his attitude is obviously that he does
not want to run again come 2024 because
he's just going to be too old so here it
was last night joe biden kind of letting
it slip that he is not running in 2024
do you plan to run for re-election yes
but look
i'm a great respecter of fate
fate has intervened in my life many many
times
if i'm in the health i'm in now
if i'm in good health
then in fact i would run again and if
that means a rematch against donald
trump
you're trying to tempt me now
sure
why would i not run against donald trump
or the nominee that increased the
prospect of running
okay so like the fact that this is a
possibility and he's speaking about it
obviously as a possibility but not a
probability is pretty telling right his
language here yes but
but if i'm in bad health then no well
what if it were to be donald trump well
you're tempting me now tempting you to
what
tempting you to what i mean when you say
that you're tempted to eat a piece of
chocolate cake what you mean is that
your
your default is to not eat the piece of
chocolate cake right if someone puts a
piece of chocolate cake in front of you
and you say i'm tempted to eat that what
you're saying is i really don't want to
eat that but now you're tempting me to
do it so what joe biden is saying there
is he really does not want to run again
in 2024 he believes he's a one-term
president because he is a one-term
president which means that democrats
have to be panicking because look at
that bench that bench is just a disaster
area and the fact that they are tethered
to an 80 year old man who is at a 41
approval rating and unable to come up
with any solution for any of the major
issues facing his administration this is
a party in deep deep trouble if you're
joking why would you want to run again
like seriously right now you go down in
history as the guy who defeated donald
trump but what happens if you come back
in 2024 and trump clocks you which by
the polls could
easily happen i mean right now donald
trump is running eight to ten points
ahead of joe biden in the national
polling now does that mean that that's
what the results of the election would
be no i mean there were polls during the
obama administration first term that
showed mitt romney beating barack obama
of course obama won re-election and
right now donald trump is benefiting
pretty heavily from the fact that the
social media companies barred him the
social media companies kicked him off
which means that you really don't see a
lot of donald trump which means that
2024 would be a referendum on joe biden
see the way presidential elections work
they're not referenda on the person who
wins their referenda on the person who
loses meaning in 2016 that election
according to the media should have been
about trump it was not it was about
hillary which is why people did not show
up for hillary in michigan and wisconsin
people were just like nope not all that
interested in hillary clinton then 2020
was a referendum on trump there's not a
single human being who voted for joe
biden because no one cares about joe
biden because joe biden is an inanimate
object joe biden is basically a block of
wood that is already mouldering and
termite written okay the only reason
anybody pulled that pulled that lever
for joe biden is because donald trump
was on the other side of the ballot well
come 2024 joe biden's been president
which means the referendum is on the
daughtering old fool who pulled out of
afghanistan so precipitously that he's
putting 19 million people in danger of
starvation
that the president of the united states
who somehow was handed a working vaccine
and yet has allowed more people to die
on his watch than the guy before the
president of the united states who said
that he was going to end the pandemic
and instead has not instead has pushed
lockdowns the president of the united
states who was handed the possibility of
a massive economic recovery and somehow
turned it into a huge inflationary
spiral and a guy who can't even get his
own party in line to vote for his
world-changing programs to build back
better right that guy
so that's a bad race for for joe biden
come 2024 the only hope for joe biden
the reason he says this about trump is
that at least donald trump is something
the american people have already done a
referendum on in 2020 and so there are a
lot of americans who aren't going to
switch their votes on trump but
joe biden has to know that 2024 does not
look good for him and so you can see his
feeble brain attempting to work here you
can see the gears slipping and then
catching here as he realizes that he's
supposed to say that he's running in
2024 but he really doesn't want to run
in 2024.
and again this should put the democrats
in a state of panic it really really
should i mean when joe biden is openly
hinting about can we ask about his
health now is that okay i mean he's
openly hinting that he may not be in the
best of health in the next couple of
years
and we all know this by the way this is
not a giant shock the man is an
octogenarian so why exactly would we
assume that he's going to be in the
shape to run in a couple of years
now again take a look at that bench
kamala harris is running in the high 20s
in approval rating
pete buda judge who's the main
qualification for office is that he is
gay okay people that is not a guy who's
qualified for office because he was the
failed mayor of south bend indiana
who then lost any statewide race he
attempted in the state of indiana
right basically they took a failed mayor
of south bend indiana
who tried to run for president
and lost and they were like but he's gay
so let's run him for president okay so
that's the other part of your bench you
got peabody judge
kamala harris who is deeply unpopular
and also only the vice president because
of her identity group membership because
she's a black woman
and then you have a cast of thousands
who nobody can recognize and nobody
knows
so the democratic party is in a whole
world of hurt and that world of hurt is
going to get worse because they've boxed
themselves in on oh micron now here's
the thing
if this party had any brains at all if
they had two brain cells to run together
all they would have to do is say that
omicron
is actually not only not a bad thing
it's actually kind of a good thing
because omicron in reality means
everyone's going to get omicron and
pretty much no one is going to die
okay by the stats we now have good
therapeutics that are available for
omicron the vaccines are basically a
guarantee against death and
hospitalization even for omicron
and even if you're unvaxed the version
of the disease that you're about to get
from omicron is significantly less
impactful than delta
there's news so what joe biden should
have said in his little speech the other
night he should have come out and he
should have said
listen i know omicron looks scary by the
media coverage but let me give you the
actual stats according to south african
data this thing is 80 less likely to
kill you than delta
which means that statistically speaking
omicron is less likely to kill you than
the flu
so
that means that if you get omicron you
shouldn't panic
if you if you start to have severe
symptoms then you should go to the
hospital otherwise you should basically
stay home if you're sick if you're
asymptomatic go to work and that's it
and we're done
right joe biden could be declaring
victory over the virus he could be
saying that thanks to vaccination we
prevented the worst of the death from
delta and from the original variant and
now thanks to vaccination even omicron
has been largely blunted
but we're lucky because now everybody's
going to get natural immunity from a
disease that is extraordinarily unlikely
to kill you
and so everybody go back to work
everybody enjoy your life have a
wonderful christmas
he could ch he could say that instead he
can't he can't he's boxed himself in
and here's the thing it's so easy to say
this it really is wall street journal
data today new data from scotland and
south africa suggest people infected
with the omicron variants of the
coronavirus are at a markedly lower risk
of hospitalization and those who
contracted earlier versions of the virus
promising signs that immunity as a
result of vaccination or prior infection
remains effective at warding off severe
illness with the fast spreading strain
the findings begin to fill in unknowns
about the severity of the disease caused
by omicron a major variable critical to
health authorities around the world as
they gauge how to react to the new
variant scientists are still unsure how
the positive findings around
hospitalizations will stack up against
another major variable oh micron's much
increased transmissibility
both variables are likely to change
depending on local conditions such as
the proportion of the population that
has been vaccinated against covet 19.
jim mcmenamin the incident director for
covet 19 at public health scotland said
this is a qualified good news story
he says a smaller proportion of a much
greater number of cases can still mean a
lot of people who might experience
severe covet infections that could lead
to hospitalization but at an absolute
level if you get omicron your chances of
being hospitalized are way lower than
they would have been with delta whether
you are vaccinated or unvaccinated
the university of edinburgh study
drawing on the health records of 5.4
million people in scotland found the
risk of hospitalization with covenant 19
was two-thirds lower with omicron than
with delta meanwhile a separate study
published by south africa's national
institute for communicable diseases
found that people infected with omicron
were 70 to 80 percent less likely to
need hospital treatment than people
infected with earlier variants including
delta
and by the way south africa is like 30
facts 25 facts that is not a heavily
vast country so that means that even if
you are unvaxed and particularly if you
have natural immunity omicron should not
pose a severe risk to you
the risk of severe complications even
among those who are admitted to the
hospital such as needing oxygen or icu
care was also reduced with omicron
compared with other variants according
to researchers in south africa
so what this means is that omicron is is
not nearly as dangerous as any anyone
here has been led to believe so this
should mean that if you're biden and
you're trying to pull out of this
tailspin now would be an excellent
excellent time for you to announce the
good news they can't announce the good
news they can't because they've created
a moral binary and the moral binary is
you are a good person if you listen to
the government and you're a bad person
if you do not listen to the government
and this is the the headline that they
are pushing today
and by the way in south africa the
disease is already subsiding
but for all the talk about how south
africa was just going to get destroyed
and it was going to be the end of the
world basically their cases went
straight up and then they went straight
down
which suggests by the way that there are
a bunch of undetected cases because
nobody actually went to the hospital or
even got a covid test because nobody
even knew they had covet
testing asymptomatic people is the
stupidest thing you can do right now
because if you test the asymptomatic and
then they come up positive they have to
go home and right now everyone's going
to get omicron and
virtually a huge percentage of the
population is going to end up
asymptomatic
so if you're asymptomatic and you're
testing everyone half half the
population is gonna have to go
quarantine for no apparent reason
okay but it's not about that for this
administration
the for this administration
it is about the the moral and premature
of covid
there's an article from the washington
post that shows this it really is kind
of incredible
as i've said before covet has become the
pagan god that you worship that if you
do the right things coveted will never
get you if you do the wrong things covet
will get you
that ain't the way real life works
so they could either discard the model
or they could instead attempt to say
that there is there's some other factor
in play namely the evils of your
neighbors we'll get to that in just one
moment first
let's say that you are a
member of a resistance band and you have
realized that reality that you seem to
see is not actual reality and you escape
the reality you seem to see you actually
enter an actual reality and the reality
answer is a lot darker and now you're
performing missions in this alternative
reality where you plug into
a computer called the matrix plug into
this virtual reality and you're
doing missions to try and take down the
machine overlords and then you receive a
phone call while you are in this virtual
reality and that phone call is a member
of your resistance band back on your
ship and he explains to you that he is
going to unplug you which would kill you
well as you start to fade away as you
say
not like as you say that
you might think to yourself man i should
have gotten life insurance policy genius
makes getting a life insurance quote
easy first you head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro you answer a
few questions about yourself in minutes
you can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their license experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you at every step until you
are covered no extra fees they won't
sell your information to third parties
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get your free life insurance quote see
how much you can save that's
policygenius.com
shapiro okay so as i say the bite
administration could be announcing the
good news they can't announce the good
news and they refuse to announce the
good news by the way the good news
doesn't end there okay pfizer their
covenant 19 pill just got authorized in
the united states that coven 19 pill
which works against omicron
it's called pax levitt
it's about to come online there should
be about a quarter million doses
available by the end of january
and that pill takes down
the rates of hospitalization and death
by something like 90 percent after you
get covid
so we have all sorts of great
therapeutics that are already there we
have great therapeutics that are coming
online omicron is way less it is way
less virulent it's much more
transmissible but way less virulent than
than prior strains and yet this
administration is is completely invested
in a moral narrative which is why you
end up with articles like this by angela
hoppt over at the washington post this
is in the wellness section
thousands who followed the rules are
about to get covered they shouldn't be
ashamed i have a question why should you
ever be ashamed that you got covered
i i don't understand why anyone would be
ashamed they got covered covet is a
disease are you ashamed that you got
cancer are you ashamed that you have
diabetes are you ashamed that you have
ibs like what disease are you ashamed of
getting
i mean the the innate assumption here is
that you have committed some great moral
sin in order for you to receive kovid
i think you should be acting like job i
did all the right things but then bad
things happen to me and your friends
come over to comfort you and offer you
various reasons as to why you weren't
strict enough in your adherence to god's
will like it's so paganistic it really
is
according to this washington post piece
for two years now aline a 30-something
graduate student in ohio has diligently
desperately even protected herself
against the coronavirus
vaccinated and boosted she took a test
last week ahead of holiday travel to
atlanta she was stunned when it came
back positive
alien who requested to be identified by
her first name only for privacy reasons
is still puzzling over how she got the
virus was it because she wore a cloth
mask rather than a medical grade one oh
you can't ask we can't ask that question
not if we wish to remain on youtube and
worries that the cough she has could now
worsen because she has diabetes that's
not the most painful part of the ordeal
though i feel very embarrassed and dumb
she says and upset that she's causing
her family stress it's eye opening that
i feel so much shame from it i'm
realizing how much judgment i was
secretly harboring against people who
got it before and this is what joe biden
is actually counting on is that you feel
that the people who got coveted are
worse than you you are good and the way
you know you are good is that you didn't
get covet and you're not getting coveted
now well all of your models are about to
break gang because everyone's getting
omicron omicron is hitting triple backs
people
everyone's getting it and guess what it
ain't gonna matter because it's
basically a cold for the vast vast vast
majority of people
the lead symptoms for omicron
are a runny nose
a slight cough and your throat hurts a
bit okay so not like the black plague
where the the first symptom was giant
bobos appearing on your body and then
death
like
it's the exact same symptoms as cold
because it is kind of a cold it is a
coronavirus that provides cold-like
symptoms the vast majority of people get
it
but says jessica stern a clinical
psychologist at nyu langone there's been
this large narrative about the
importance of controlling your actions
to prevent yourself from getting sick
and from transmitting the illness to
other people because the narrative is so
closely connected to our behaviors i
think there's this implication or this
assumption that if you get sick you must
have done something wrong to bring it on
to yourself that's not true she stresses
but unfortunately it's inherent in the
way we've been thinking about and
talking about kovid that can lead to
shame which cern defines as the
combination of embarrassment or guilt
and identity one of the most visceral
emotions
so yes
i'm amused that people on the left who
are starting to realize that anyone can
get coveted you can do the right things
and still get coveted only when it hits
them do they realize that they've been
judgmental jackasses this entire time
by the way the washington post will in
the section offer some tips on how to
clamp down on your feelings of guilt
one psychologist says we're going to
tell people acknowledge the emotion try
to recognize what it is we know we're in
an environment right now where there's a
lot of judgment and it makes sense you
might be feeling mortified at the idea
others will think you behaved carelessly
sue varma psychiatrist says do you have
perfectionist standards was staying
healthy your way of regaining control
during an impossible trying stretch of
time
set it aside in favor of proper health
protocols
don't make sure that you tell everybody
else that you have covered because you
don't want to you don't want to be in a
situation where you infect somebody also
don't over explain
one psychiatrist says you might be
preemptively defensive telling people
who didn't ask you have taken safety
protocol seriously
say i'm super careful but it got to me
but it got me anyway and consider it a
learning experience okay i'm sorry this
is all rooted in a moral lie which is
that if you got coveted
in the first place it's because you're a
bad human
and this is why it was all connected in
2020 to the politics of black lives
matter if you're a good human and you
support black lives matter you won't get
the virus ever you will be fine if
you're a bad human and you go partying
out in the ozarks this means you'll get
covered because you're a bad human
because you weren't in a black lives
matter alley
this entire
bizarre paganistic standard for behavior
continues to to percolate among
democrats and joe biden can't get out of
it because if joe biden were to just say
live your life enjoy your life that
might say that the people who made the
sacrifices the people who did the right
thing they're no better than the others
uh oh uh oh that would be terrible
that'd be terrible and so they're gonna
continue to clamp down and lyanna went
over on cnn she's urging more of this
right liana wen who's the mo i mean
honestly she has a job on tv in order to
be the sky is falling
crazy homeless person on a street corner
in new york or cartoon right the end of
the world is coming here's lyanna went
saying we should go further to restrict
human activity
i do have a lot of concern about what
happens to parts of this country for
example that have very low vaccination
rates and this is another reason why i
think president biden's message
yesterday was the right one was the
right one in some way in saying
vaccinated people should move on with
their lives with precautions but i wish
that he would go further to restrict the
activities of the unvaccinated because
they are the ones who are still
spreading covet and prolonging the
pandemic for all of us
again
notice that last part right they're the
ones who are prolonging the pandemic
it's them and they are doing really
because it seems like there's a giant
spike in new york city with the mass
mandates and with the vax mandates and
with the vaccine passports and all the
rest it seems like there's a giant spike
pretty much everywhere so it seems once
omicron has broken all of your prior
assumptions about pandemic maintaining
those assumptions demonstrates fealty to
a religious point of view it does not
demonstrate fealty to data in any way
shape or form speaking of fealty to a
religious point of view and not to the
data the supreme court is about to hold
a special session on the biden vaccine
rules is broke late last night the
supreme court said it would hear
arguments on an expedited basis on
president joe biden's coven 19 shot or
test rule for large employers and his
separate vaccine mandate for health care
workers the justices are going to hear
both cases at a special january 7th
session we of course are one of the
plaintiffs in the case against the
federal government with regard to the
the vax mandate please go sign our
petition over at dailywire.com do not
comply we have hit a million signatures
thanks to you we really appreciate your
help in doing that the justices are
going to hear arguments from business
groups and republican-led states that
argue that osha exceeded its powers
ohio is leading a separate group of 27
states challenging the osha rule the the
business groups are being led by the
national federation of independent
business so
we will see how the supreme court comes
down on that but again it's going to be
very hard to argue in favor of a vax
mandate for businesses given the simple
fact that the vaccinated are
transmitting omicron that omicron is
hitting the vaccinated and the whole
purpose of the vacuum mandate is to
protect people from other people
infecting them well um the vaccinated
are passing omicron so you're going to
have to explain why a vax mandate is now
necessary and you can't say that osha is
designed in order to quote unquote
protect people from themselves that's
not what osha is designed to do it's
designed to protect the workplace
right osha is not a rule saying that we
can ban smoking because we have to
protect you from your lung cancer it's
that you're not allowed to smoke in the
workplace because it might affect other
people in the workplace and you have to
be guaranteed a safe workplace
and so the vaccine mandate is likely to
come up for for debate before the
supreme court early january and
hopefully it will be struck down by the
supreme court at that point meanwhile
joe biden
is now admitting some regrets i mean the
mixed messaging that is now coming from
the democratic party over omicron is
really astonishing it's they're all over
the place because omicron has just
scrambled their playbook it's really
messed with their playbook we'll get to
that in just one moment first we know
there are a lot of people who are almost
impossible to shop for your thing about
christmas and what do i do for christmas
and and what do i get them well let me
give you a great gift that's great for
pretty much everyone the gift everyone
wants is that better night sleep but i'm
telling you you need a great pair of
sheets that is bull and branch bowling
branch is so good my wife and i put it
on our bed every single night we took
all of our other sheets and we just
don't sleep on them we gave them away we
got them for our kids they are just that
good husband and wife team scott and
missy tannen founded bowling branch to
create a new standard in betting by
doing things the right way not the easy
way they hold themselves to high
standards across the board they make
great pillows bath towels robes their
signature hem sheets these are the
all-time best seller the reason for that
is because they actually fit your
mattress you've ever been sleeping on a
hem sheet and suddenly you roll over and
your face is directly on the mattress
you wake up in the morning like uh that
has never happened with a bowl and
branch sheet because these sheets are
just fantastic they fit the bed
perfectly plus they are buttery soft
lightweight made with 100 organic cotton
weave that feels incredible in all
seasons it's completely toxin free fair
trade certified treat yourself and your
loved ones to the new standard in
bedding from bowl and branch their gifts
come wrapped and ready in their special
holiday packaging today is the last day
to get the best deals of the year with
promo code shapiro at bullanbranch.com
that's bol and branch.com promo code
shapiro exclusions may apply okay so joe
biden has created a model for himself in
terms of policy and can't uphold the
model for himself in terms of policy
because model never made any sense so
for example joe biden the other day
pledged she was going to get 500 million
home tests out available for americans
with regard to covet
and then even close to what needs to
happen right we need billions probably
because omicron will hit everyone also
what is the purpose of the home test you
shouldn't be testing if you're
asymptomatic
you should not just assume you're going
to get omicron okay just at this point
if you're a human assume that you're
going to get omicron
and that if you're a vexed you'll be
fine and if you're unvaxed you're also
very likely to be fine
because them's the stats
okay but joe biden is stuck because he
said that the tests are really important
right so important he's gonna make 500
million of them available to the
american people there's only one problem
thanks to the fda's refusal under joe
biden to greenlight the test and thanks
to his own administration's failings the
tests ain't available so here is joe
biden yesterday admitting uh yeah i
regret not having made martial but
nobody could have expected it says joe
biden nobody could have expected this as
we will see that is just a lie
empty shelves and no test kits in some
places
three days before christmas when it's so
important
is that good enough
no nothing's been good enough
okay he says nothing has been good
enough nothing okay but then he says
that he tried his best but he never
could have foreseen he never could have
foreseen that something like this would
happen
he he literally said i don't think it's
a failure i think you could argue we
should have known a year ago six months
ago two months ago a month ago i wish i
had thought about ordering 500 million
at-home tests two months ago
okay that's weird because politico
provides a timeline january 22nd biden
promised a war footing to aggressively
speed up covet 19 response especially on
testing february 17th biden announced a
series of new actions to expand covet 19
testing
march 11th biden said we continue to
work on making at-home testing available
july 6th biden said we're going to
deploy things like testing to expand
detection of the virus september 9th he
promised to use the defense production
act to increase production of rapid
tests
december 2nd he said we're going to make
free at-home tests more available than
ever before december 6th
gensake said why not make them free and
give them out to everyone should we just
send one to every american now they're
saying they're going to
so
yeah they they're not they didn't do
their job so even the job they said they
were going to do they just didn't do
and meanwhile joe biden continues to be
all over the place with regard to vax
mandates because on the one hand he
wants to maintain that his vast mandate
on a major business is a good idea on
the other hand he wants to say that you
don't need a vast mandate for travel
this is completely discombobulated and
if you have to say that joe biden is
likely to rectify this this
discontinuity in one way or the other
either he's going to make you vax to
travel or he's going to get rid of the
vax mandate he's likely to try to make
you vaccinate travel that is probably
the next move by this administration
which is truly egregious
right
the planes are not the place where the
virus is being passed they have hepa
filters if you go to your house and
someone has covid you're much more
likely to get covered than if you're on
a plane with somebody with covet
but the discombobulation is the point
they have no plan because their plans
are stupid and make no sense
now the other day i was reading fa
hayek's constitution of liberty again
and one of the things that fa hayek
frederick hayek the great economist says
in the constitution of liberty is quote
governments which start out with a proud
claim that they will deliberately
control all affairs soon find themselves
to be said at each step by the
necessities created by their former
actions in other words you start with a
bad premise and you make a bad law and
then in order to fix the bad law you
make another bad law and in order to fix
that bad law you have to make a third
bad law and pretty soon you have an
entire rubric of terrible laws all
interlocking with each other based on
your original bad premise that's exactly
what has happened here
so for joe biden do vaccinates work or
do they not work
we have no clue because for example here
is joe biden talking about the vax
mandate with regard to truckers a lot of
people are saying we have supply chain
problems what happens when 30 of
truckers who aren't vast are fired from
their jobs because they are not vast
here's your buy and say don't worry
about it won't be a problem and we are
going to maintain that vax mandate
the trucking
industry positioning the supreme court
to repeal their vaccine mandate they
think that it's going to harm the supply
chains recovery
i say no
thank you
okay i say no uh thank you there's my
crazy joker smile oh well if you say no
to reality then magically reality will
conform to you but here's the thing joe
biden's like don't worry we're gonna do
a vac mandate on the truckers then he's
asked okay well how about vax mandates
for travel
and he's like well i don't think we have
to do that explain truly
explain why a trucker alone in the cabin
of his truck needs to be vact but you
don't need to be back to get on a plane
joe biden
it makes no sense obviously
have you considered requiring passengers
in this country to be vaccinated to get
on flights
it's been considered but the
recommendation i've gotten is not
necessary even with omicron even with
omicron that's the recommendation i got
so far
from the team
so um he is uh he's gonna back off of
this you watch within the next three
weeks joe biden is going to be calling
for a vac mandate for travel meaning you
won't be able to get on a plane unless
you provide proof of vaccination which
is just hideous so this is all hideous
and stupid and pointless
by the way when reality hits it turns
out that people back off the reality so
for example the air force has now
extended its vast deadline for the air
national guard by nearly a month
becoming the first service to roll back
policy outlined by the pentagon to get
most of the troops vaccinated by the end
of the year previously all air guard
members had until december 2 to get
fully vaccinated but on wednesday the
service said the deadline was now
december 31. why was it extended well
that's because the rate of people who
got vast in the air national guard is
actually pretty low
only about 92 percent of air guard
members had received at least one dose
that means over 6 100 airmen who have
not had any dose at all
so the air national guard's like okay so
we have a choice which is we can either
be wildly unprepared for a war or we can
just stop with this crap at least for
the moment the nba is doing the same
thing right the nba was saying well you
know we have we had this bubble last
year we were so worried about covid and
uh and we even paused the season on the
original but we're not pausing the
season now we're never pausing the
season now we have to go forward the
show must go on and and now they're
being praised by the media for this
weird because i have been
informed reliably that covet is the
worst thing ever to happen and we can't
get together in crowded areas unless
apparently you're adam silver in the nba
no plans right now to pause the season
we've of course looked at all the
options
but frankly um we're having trouble
coming up with what the logic would be
behind pausing right now as we look
through these cases
literally ripping through the country
right now putting aside the rest of the
world
um i think we're finding ourselves where
we sort of knew we were going to get to
for the past several months and that is
that this
virus will not be eradicated and we're
going to have to learn to live with it
and i think that's what we're
experiencing in the league right now
so in other words kyrie irving couldn't
play it for months and months and months
and months because he was unvaccinated
but we're getting rid of basically all
of the requirements that would be
necessary in order to push our original
standard because the show must go on
and it's endemic bill de blasio doing
the same thing right the commie outgoing
mayor of new york he says keep living
man we're not shutting down man this
captain shut down over here
acknowledging the reality
we're not telling uh vaccinated people
to stop living their lives uh we're
saying take for you know climb that
ladder of vaccination if you haven't
done the full vaccination course yet go
do it
keep living because we're not going to
shut down i want to be very clear we
didn't i do not believe in shutdowns
shutdowns are counterproductive at this
point vaccination is the key and there's
still plenty more people who could get
vaccinated or get that booster
okay we're not shutting down we're going
to keep on living meanwhile washington
dc has now announced a cover 19 vaccine
requirement for nearly everything
indoors according to tim meade's writing
at daily wire
muriel bowser announced wednesday
individuals 12 and up will be required
to show proof of vaccine starting
january 15th 2022 to do anything
so you have to do this at restaurants
bars nightclubs indoor cultural and
entertainment facilities indoor exercise
and recreational establishments indoor
event and meeting establishments
also eligible students in dc will be
required to receive the coveted 19
vaccine beginning on march 1st 2022 so
now your choices are that you can either
go to a failing dc school or you cannot
go to a failing dc school and learn the
same exact amount that's the those are
the those are the choices over in
washington dc lori lightfoot doing the
same thing over in chicago again it's
all discombobulated and it makes no
sense and it makes no sense because all
of their premises about the pandemic
were wrong from the get-go
you are morally evil if you get coveted
if you have natural immunity that is
completely worthless there's no reason
to even talk about it
you can prevent yourself from getting
covered if you just do these three magic
things from buzzfeed
you're a bad person if you don't listen
to the author
again all this is being proved but wrong
by omicron and they can't get but
they can't just say what is obvious
which is move on with your life because
if they do that it's a tacit admission
they've been getting it wrong nearly the
entire time lori lightfoot tweeted
simply
to put it simply if you have been living
vaccine-free your time is up
if you wish to live life with the ease
to do the things you love you must be
vast
meanwhile gavin newsom is saying
healthcare workers have to boost they
don't just have to be backed they have
to boost
so to be clear one of the things we are
worried about now is healthcare
shortages right shortages in hospitals
lack of nurses and gavin newsom's like
well what if we fire half of our nurses
because they won't backs
amazing amazingly short-sighted garbage
that led to extraordinarily high
vaccination rates for our healthcare
workers
kept staff working kept the morale
strong kept their immunity strong but we
recognize now that just being vaccinated
fully vaccinated is not enough with this
new variant and we believe it's
important to extend this requirement to
getting that third dose to getting
boosted and so uh we are formalizing
that february 1st is the deadline to get
that done
or you're going to fire them and then
there and then there will be shortages
again and there will be shortages again
it is truly amazing how far they are
willing to go in the direction of
paranoia and fear
in order to promulgate policy that is
likely to have precisely the opposite of
its intended effect it really is an
amazing thing meanwhile you have the
entire media still trying to blame fox
news for for all of this despite the
fact that omicron is hitting pretty much
everyone including the triple vacs again
people who are vulnerable should be
getting vaxxed i have been saying this
consistently since day one my wife is
triple facts both my parents are triple
vacs i am double vaxxed because i'm 37
years old and after a consultation with
marty mccary johns hopkins university he
has suggested that there's really no
necessity for me to get the booster shot
because i have t-cell and b-cell memory
in any case joy reid is still
maintaining the case that if you don't
listen to joy reid this means you want
people to die for fun
probably the most vaccinated company in
america is fox news they're all
vaccinated they're going to live through
this and let their viewers and their
fans die because they don't give a damn
it's just clicks to them it's just
they don't care what happens
this is fun for them
it's fun for them it's fun for them to
watch their viewers die again they can't
let go of the moral narrative they'll
never let go of the moral narrative just
a reminder just a reminder the moral
narrative that was originally driven by
the left was the narrative that you must
not greenlight the vaccine in the first
place
technologyreview.com october 19th 2020
one doctor's campaign to stop a covet 19
vaccine being rushed through before
election day
how heart dr eric topel used his social
media accounts to kill off trump's
october surprise
okay remember it was the left that was
pushing
hard
to to not allow the fda and cdc to clear
distribution of the vaccine because
trump was still president
remember pfizer was supposed to clear
the vaccine like the last week of
october right before the election
and people for political reasons decided
they would rather see a hundred thousand
americans die and allow the vaccine to
be greenlit under trump
according to technology review after
being released from walter reed national
military medical center on october 5th
u.s president donald trump praised the
doctors who treated him for coven 19
promised the public would soon have a
vaccine against the deadly coronavirus
we have the best medicines in the world
and very shortly they're all getting
approved and the vaccines are coming
momentarily he said in a video across
the country in california a doctor named
eric topel was responding in real time
on social media he questioned the
president's health his doctor's action
even his mental status
by that point topel a heart expert and
researcher with a huge twitter following
was already weeks into a personal
campaign to make sure the administration
could not rush a covid19 vaccine through
regulatory authorization before election
day on november 3rd
an editorial in the new york times had
raised the possibility of an october
surprise vaccine back in june and warned
that a vaccine approval could turn into
a campaign stunt
topple aimed to prevent trump from
greenlighting a vaccine before
scientists could prove it to be safe and
effective
if trump badgered the fda into
prematurely releasing a vaccine it could
shake the public's trust in any covenant
19 vaccine
releasing a vaccine that people are
afraid of could do more harm than good
so toppo led online calls for fda
commissioner steve hans resign after his
agency was criticized for cowing to
political pressure and then phoned han
to urge him to resist trump's influence
topple targeted pfizer which eventually
set up a meeting for him with its
vaccine team topple and his allies
claimed success on october 16th pfizer
ceo albert borla said the company would
not be able to seek emergency approval
for its vaccine before the third week in
november owing to safety standards that
had been put in place by the fda
those standards had been issued against
trump's wishes at the urging of topple
and other advocates so remember all
these people who say it's all apolitical
it's all about fighting the virus they
literally delayed the distribution of
this of this vaccine by at least a month
which meant probably a hundred thousand
dead americans from delta
because of this
because because they because they
desired that trump not get his october
surprise so never tell me that politics
has not been a part of this it's been a
part it's been a part of this since the
very damned beginning
and people have died because of it for
sure but that all that on trump and and
the vax deniers a lot of that is on the
left that
like you know how insane that is you
know what i'm saying it is that eric
topple one doctor at scripps
basically prevented hundreds of
thousands of americans from getting the
vaccine at say the beginning of january
rather than the middle of february
it's totally crazy
okay we'll get to the biden policy in
just one second again joe biden he's
making pretty obvious that he doesn't
really want to run for president in 2024
there are a lot of reasons why we'll get
some more of those in a second first if
you're looking for ways to skip the trip
to the post office and dodge all that
hectic holiday shopping traffic why not
save time and money with stamps.com
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels access exclusive discounts on ups
and usps shipping services all year long
it makes a lot of sense especially if
your business is sending a lot of stuff
out around holiday time here at the
daily wear we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 no more wasting our time
whether you're selling online or running
an office or side hustle stamps.com can
save you so much time money and stress
during the holidays access the post
office and usps shipping services you
need without taking the trip get
discounts you can't find anywhere else
40 off usps rates 76 off ups rates we've
been using stamps.com at the daily wire
for years and years and years and years
there's no reason to waste your time and
waste your money
instead go to stamps.com sign up with
promo code shapiro for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just head on
over to stamps.com click the microphone
at the top of the page enter code
shapiro again the stamps.com click the
mic at the top of the page enter code
shapiro to get started okay meanwhile
your dreams are coming true because we
have huge news here at our daily wire
south florida offices that means this
office where we film every day our team
is growing we are searching for a
talented new producer to join us and
support our efforts in the production of
a bunch of new and exciting projects we
have going on we have so much going on
at this office and we desperately need a
producer or line producer if you've got
at least five years of previous
professional producer or line producer
experience and strong skills in leading
and managing others if you're an avid
consumer of all things politics news and
pop culture this could be the
opportunity on the dw team you have been
waiting for again this position is based
at our south florida offices you could
be like within within just a couple of
weeks you could be standing behind this
camera right here could be you to learn
more about the position and apply and to
view a full list of our current openings
at daily wire please visit dailywire.com
careers also if you have not seen
candice owens's full face-to-face
unscripted conversation with president
trump you're missing out this week we
released an exclusive interview between
candace and trump it's pretty great
check out this teaser
welcome to a most special episode of
candace
each time that i've interviewed
president trump they have never told me
that i am not allowed to ask him
anything
today i want to talk about some topics
that are on i think everybody's mind
[Music]
where do you stand on these vaccine
mayonnaise what's going on there you
talk about mass you talk about mandates
julian assange edward snowden i mean you
could have had a chance to pardon these
individuals you have two sides of it
anything that looking back you think i
got that one wrong did you get covered
no did you have the vaccine no
no kitty i'm very impressed with you
alec baldwin is he going to get arrested
i think he's crazy this is the toughest
question i could possibly ask you tell
me one good thing joe biden has done in
office she's done this before right he
is completely unscripted it's one of the
things that fascinates me about him what
you see is exactly what you get
all right mr president
the interview is streaming exclusively
to members at dailywire.com head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe to join today
start watching and if you dig candace
head on over to the yesweecandis.com
store pick up some awesome candace merch
also we are we've hit a million
signatures on our daily wire petition
before christmas as hoped thank you for
helping us out we really appreciate it
and if you haven't signed please
continue to sign because those
signatures will be used by us in our
push against the biden vax mandates
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay meanwhile joe biden continues to
push forward radical policy it's it's
amazing to me
how much radical policy this guy
continues to push even though
it's just not making him popular he's
catering to the left wing and i i for
the life of me i will never understand
the political malpractice in which he is
currently engaged according to cnn joe
biden has now extended his pause on
student loan repayment through may 1st
why
through may 1st
it is now december 23rd through may 1st
so we're going to go like another five
six months without people having to
repay their student loans for what
reason exactly
the current unemployed he's bragging
about it the current unemployment rate
in the country is 4.2 percent
people are back at work
people have savings because you blew
money into their pockets over the course
of the last two years but they don't
have to pay their their loans their
student loans back
why exactly
why as a person who paid back not only
my own student loans but also my wife's
student loans i'd like to ask why
please explain
really what is your logic here
biden said in a statement that because
of the ongoing covet 19 crisis people
can't pay back their student loans
really so people who generally have
unpaid student loans we're talking about
a 25 year old who ain't gonna die of
omicron and
almost certainly was not going to die of
delta
biden said given these considerations
today my administration is extending the
pause on federal student loan repayments
for an additional 90 days
through may 1 2022 as we manage the
ongoing pandemic and further strengthen
our economic recovery meanwhile the
department of education will continue
working with borrowers to ensure they
have the support they need to transition
smoothly back into repayments and
advance economic stability for their own
households and for our nation
that reversal came less than two weeks
after the white house press secretary
gensake indicated the administration
would plan to restart federal student
loan payments in february
the possible extension was first
reported by politico borrower balances
have been frozen for two
years two years
some democrats want it longer right
elizabeth warren ayanna presley
chuck schumer elizabeth warren and
ayanna presley put out a statement
saying extending the pause will help
millions of americans make ends meet
especially as we overcome the omicron
variant
but they want biden to take further
action and just simply cancel up to 50
grand of student loan debt per borrower
for the people who are the most highly
educated and thus likely the most high
income in the united states makes
perfect sense
just genius genius policy from this
administration of course by the way
nobody would ever engage in bad behavior
with all the money we've blown into the
system i mean it's not as though people
stole like 100 billion dollars in
coveted relief funds oh wait that's
exactly what happened according to cnbc
criminals have stolen close to 100
billion dollars in pandemic relief funds
according to the secret service
the stolen funds were diverted by
fraudsters from the small business
administration's paycheck protection
program the economic injury disaster
loan program and another program set up
to dole out unemployment assistance
funds nationwide
only about 2.3 billion in stolen funds
have been recovered so far
so they lost 100 billion but the good
news is they found 2.3 billion dollars
in stolen funds which sounds like the
government
they sound like they're they're great at
this
assistant special agent in charge roy
dodson said i've been in law enforcement
for over 29 years i've worked some
complex fraud investigations for 20 plus
years i've never seen anything at this
scale
he said there's no doubt the programs
were easily accessible online
that brings the opportunity for bad
actors to get into the mix it was
necessary to try to get those funds out
to people that were truly hurting
nobody's at fault well i feel like some
people are at fault when you lose a
hundred billion dollars
just randomly whoops
but but don't worry guys everything is
going great this administration they
just they know what they are doing they
are experts and because they are experts
you should listen to everything they
have to say and if you don't listen to
what they have to say and then you get
omicron it's because it's your fault you
see
it's because it's your fault by the way
the law of unintended consequences
remains undefeated
you have to love this final story of our
broadcast year
on the on the live podcast
this is an amazing story a democratic
member of congress was carjacked and
robbed in philadelphia after backing
defund the police representative mary
gay scanlan represents pennsylvania's
fifth district carjacked and robbed at
gunpoint in south philadelphia in broad
daylight
so yeah uh yeah you couldn't see that
one coming at all
defund the police get carjacked
welcome to democratic policy literally
being mugged by reality well the
democrats in 2022 are going to be mugged
by reality on mass and it's going to be
beautiful to watch we've reached the end
of today's program we will be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content i did want to tell you we are so
grateful for your listenership this year
we cannot wait to bring you all sorts of
amazing amazing stuff in the brand new
year and we hope that you will subscribe
over at dailywire.com if you've not
become a subscriber a lot of the new
content is going to be only available
for subscribers
again i hope you have a wonderful
christmas i hope you have a wonderful
wonderful new year and i cannot wait to
see you again next year because it's
going to be a lot of fun in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
that's available right now i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the media get caught in another covid
live ted cruz floats a 2024 presidential
run and president trump enjoins people
to embrace the vaccines check it out on
the michael knowles show